reject nation welcome to the reaction
station as we hail after chip and dale
we gonna watch ourselves some sonic
after the ugly sonic we gonna watch part
two of sonic injecting the blue hedgehog
in our veins like chronic
fighting mr robotnik
bionic
probiotics hey hey you're gonna watch
ourselves our hedgehog 2. get yourself a
chili dog i did not see this in the
theaters doing a reaction today for you
guys hey if you can leave a like that'd
be very much appreciated also subscribe
and click that notification bell to get
notified when our next special reaction
is up here on the channel as always
special thanks to all you super sexy
rejects that we will never forget for
subscribing to our patreon page over
there you get the full length reaction
watch along we sing up with the timecode
along with a bunch of other stuff that
we cover as well lastly then boys at
prepper if you guys are looking for some
editing help wait till july but then
then you yeah do it
[Music]
[Music]
god damn that's some mean kombucha i've
been striving to make fungi into a
functional drink of choice mushroom
coffee
with limited
limited
limited
success
i'll come back to earth dude you'll be
right in style let's light this candle
and see who comes in knocking
knocking is something you do with your
knuckles
that joke makes you want to chuckle ha
ha
uh the clan
ancient babylon they look human-sized
yeah
oh my god i've always wanted that now
[Music]
piece of shiitake planet
classic kid-friendly swear
it's happening
nice
where did you get that
from a little blue menace on the planet
called earth i'd be happy to show you
the way
i forgot the name of that group are they
called babylonians or something sticks
in my mind vaguely from the lore
all the money's getting lost sonic
[Music]
you guys got a budget bigger this time
come here no need to thank me citizens
i was going over there you get any bites
[Music]
what's in there i wouldn't come any
closer because this little hedgehog had
way too many chili dogs oh no oh no i'm
so embarrassed get out of here quick oh
no
[Laughter]
save yourself
stop right there i wouldn't come any
closer
i'm so embarrassed
i knew i should use real farts
always use real fart trust me when i
tell you there will come a time when
your powers will be needed but you don't
choose that moment that moment chooses
you wait a second did you steal that
from oprah came from my dad he would
always try and steer me in the right
direction that's what maddie and i have
always tried to do with you you should
have real kids
[Laughter]
we'll see how this one goes first all
right we're off okay be good yes
do you have our number sorry can't hear
you you're traveling through a
cross-dimensional portal miss you
already okay have fun at rachel's
wedding
that is so cool
oh my god sonic
this was my dream growing up
[Music]
oh my good hey
what a good guy sonic is that's not how
you pay for food man he's here i found
him
i just hope i'm not too late
miles per hour has entered the game
[Music]
can't fail with tails any other partner
can pay pals
like yeah and faster than snail mails
so how's rachel's fiance is he as good
looking in person as he is in pictures
yeah damn
hello
oh blackout
[Laughter]
excuse me we did not order a poltergeist
back from the dead
egg man
[Music]
oh no you're gonna have to fix this
house up
you're never going to get my power do i
look like i need your power
guys are destroying the house
not gonna be able to run this back to
being fixed
oh i forgot about this shot that is so
cool
oh man
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
get us out of here
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that stopped him
damn this one is shot so good
holy crap
they're really packing a punch i got an
idea do you trust me of course not i
literally just met you
i wish somebody would say that in one of
these movies
yes
how's that for a power
[Music]
oh god norah jones just a couple of
songs hold up
[Laughter]
good night
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
buddy
oh awesome
you're suggesting an alliance around
here we simply
grip each other's hands tightly
[Laughter]
we need to figure out why knuckles
thinks i'm the key to finding the master
emerald and why did he mention longclaw
there must be a connection that's why he
mentioned it i never knew what it meant
before
something's happening
long claw
long claw looks like league of legends
this world has been chosen for a very
important reason it's the secret
location
of the master emerald why did this
activate before you're coming with me oh
no no no no i just came here to warn you
i'm not a field guy don't worry i got
your back i won't let anything happen to
you
responsibility for others on earth it
means an unbreakable promise
okay
i'm in
i've made what so many unbreakable
promises
welcome to the team
[Music]
that means he trusts you stone
[Music]
hub stone gets to meet other stone dude
idiots alba is perfect as knuckles
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah dork hang with you and your
groomsmen good
quality bonding uh you know bro
those guys right there they're way more
than my groomsmen that's my squad
[Laughter]
dude that's how we hang out with sonic
had that
muscles
control yourself
muscles is probably a character
muscles will be here for the sequel
run
my inventions are how i discovered you
remember that night at the baseball
field from the first move oh call backs
so you've been watching me this whole
time
even in the shower
ah that's a trick question
sonic the hedgehog prefers bubble baths
man you're good but yes i've been
watching you based in the bubble bath
just chilling
watching tv
dot dot dot
dot dot dot
[Laughter]
i say we ditch him ghost and blow him
off dishonor
this
is how i roll
the first step into their alliance
faltering justice for stone
uh
meow
prostitutes
they're americans yeah we must kill them
burn them alive there's gotta be
something in here tails whatever you're
doing do it fast
[Applause]
it's a siberian custom to resolve
disputes you win they let us go if we
lose
[Applause]
there's a lot of
[Music]
oh my god oh my god yes
oh my god it's a dance fight
[Applause]
i did not see that company
that's hilarious
oh shirtless men in this movie
it's about time
kids love pecs
[Music]
[Music]
not in the pants
these are children
wow you guys are so in sync
the lights just follow your leads
[Laughter]
burn them their witches you can't
compete with that you can't do that
that's just humanly impossible yes
you beat him
i'll take that
you are now the leaders
night tails
be big spoon come on
those two are adorable together up town
funk you up
[Laughter]
the master emerald
with it
a single warrior could defeat entire
armies
that's really his lord of the rings
we are the owls of cahool
[Music]
it's time to snowboard you go high i go
low right quick little stretch and here
we go
stretch the other side of your body too
sonic
it's pretty cool
[Applause]
i too will snow
the board
i've paid attention to extreme sports
awesome
it's too easy come on
challenge me
now you got this
sonic oh it's quick silver moment
[Music]
i love those slow motion scenes
my father stopped me from joining the
fight he said my moment to honor our
tribe would come but it was not this
moment i never saw him again
go on
goodbye sonic
[Music]
oh
sonic are you okay deceiver
[Music]
tails come on wake up you chose helping
the fox over pursuing the compass of
course he did
new friends same pathetic weakness
i might not stick around to hang with
you by the end of this movie loyalty
weakness
see you kids enjoy the fresh powder
i could survive an avalanche yeah what's
the big deal
all right signify
nah
ah classic theme
these rings
[Music]
so help me thomas
i need you to use the ring i gave you to
save me like right now
it could have been ash ketchum
you need is your hat
oh god what what tell me what oh god
[Music]
rip your hand apart i very much want to
know before i become a hedgehog flavored
snow cone hang tight buddy
i got this oh
golly hey
hi oh you can't watch this
this is embarrassing put the ring on my
finger listen to me randall look at me
ring on my face give me the ring give me
just one second put a ring on it with
this wrap yes i'm so sorry about this
whoa oh god
[Music]
what have you done the two of you have
such a toxic relationship creating
destruction in your personal lives whose
tail tails can you hear me no oh lord
there are two of them
now okay
whoa
why do all of your friends have weapons
oh no
you really should have taken me up on
that brunch mr and mrs wakowski
olive garden guy oh the guarded
[Laughter]
did he ever really love her operation
catfish
so is everyone here an agent
are you an agent
in a bible sonic is not a threat he's on
our side he's an uncontrolled
extraterrestrial and your days of aiding
and abetting them are over secure them
in the hotel until the chopper arrives
while we are here we are not family i
have an idea
and i want to have a word with my fiance
that word is murder
kids love murder
murder
what do you think about that
[Music]
whoa
yeah
nice
i got a fiancee to vaporize electroboxes
[Laughter]
oh
you know you love her you got too deep
undercover man
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
stop right there
you
son of a have it your way no
whoa
hell hath no fury like a bride scorn
wow
looks like it's real huh
i didn't think that i was even capable
of real happiness
but that all changed when you walked
into my life and i ended up breaking the
first rule of undercover work
which is never fall in love happens all
the time when you infiltrate gangs man
yep i always just fall in love with each
other
it's like just fly spike
the ultimate sky beam
and well since skyping started to miss
him
closed
doesn't seem right oh my god this
robotics i gotta tell everybody
close
yeah you are about him
classic suit
you can do this
[Music]
i gotta go fast
awesome our lord and savior sonic christ
wow
wowie
epic shot it's like a godzilla movie
shot
come on sonic oh you got this bro
does he conveniently washed ashore
oh
here it goes i don't want to die like
this it's derivative
oh god
great i've solved it
there's a booby trap every seven seconds
oh
yes
get a little trim that was a little
oh
early
glad it didn't cut off my
mustache oh your penis yep
oh here we go
yes
sonic and knuckles
oh [ __ ]
super sonic
cool
oh
yes this is bad news
chaos
is
power
this is chaos magic wonder
let's get out of here
[Music]
i'm gonna have to save him
poor knuckles i feel so bad for him no
he was like
he's like you're my friend
it breaks my heart
[Music]
wait here are you that are you that
dense
that heavy
he just broke his head that crunch
don't talk to me i'm not in the mood
how dare you attack me in my hour of
sorrow
why did you save me
[Music]
that's not good
oh my god
i'm upgrading
[Laughter]
congratulations on your oh so temporary
sense of superiority you're finished
robotnik we've taken everything your lab
your drones your funding let's see how
big of a man you are without your silly
little robots
why'd you challenge him can't you see
he's sparkly yeah
magneto no
he's taking everything apart
oh he's building building something yeah
hope you're not so mad i hit you with
that car
i was completely uninjured and my
revenge will come when you least expect
he's gonna kill tales
that is awesome man
there's a lot of awesome things in this
movie guys
yep
yes
yes so it's like a boss battle it's
perfect so we make our stand here on the
field of battle as a team
this is it this is our
moment
they are so adorable and cool
love the egghead design
bad time to say this but i don't
actually have a plan
oh you mentioned that a few times that
in fact
i know what his weak spot is it's me i'm
the groin
think about it i look rent-free in this
dude's head so
no
[Applause]
he flipped it
ouch boom
complimentary colors
you
crank beautiful man it takes a lot of
courage beautiful thank you
for making me feel safe enough
it's really shrunk since back in the
labyrinth
oh
[Music]
thank goodness they're ready to kill
them off and we'd have spent 20 minutes
doing this sonic would be like
that must have been you
what
it's cracked man
use the individual emeralds i love you
guys
we love you too simon
[Music]
yeah
oh my god
[Music]
super saiyan sonic
oh
yeah
take a little off the top
it's over eggman wow
yeah
[Music]
come on
this might be the best video game movie
ever
you sure about that nux oh you gotta try
this
it's truly a beautiful day for baseball
all right give him the heat tails hope
you're ready for my fastball your
fastball will be dishonored
[Laughter]
powerbomb
victory is mine i think that was our
only ball
[Laughter]
can't forget this
[Music]
i was really impressed with that movie
it feels like a really natural sequel to
the first one and yeah but yet so much
bigger yeah
and so it's so different from the first
one but also really fits
like a writer's remove we need to
reinvent this to make it feel like a
like more like the game or something
level this up
it's a real natural progression this is
something much more high stakes and a
file buried deep in our system and
dating back over 50 years
what was it coordinates sir to what
a secret research facility oh my
someone worked very hard to keep this
head
shadow shadow
project shadow
oh
here we go the last trailer reaction say
that i hope they bring shadowing
not bad
good on james marston for that top
billing
very fun
lots of imagination a lot of punch
shadow
it's bad
[Laughter]
so knuckles and tails remaining on earth
i guess so yeah they're gonna chill
they're gonna live with the uh
wackowskis but what about the
what about um knuckles family the the
mordecai's or the echidna
they're all gone he's the only one now i
was like it's not acne guy that's a
fight challenge and uh
and
avatar
close enough
keep forgetting that
i was a little confused
we saw the echidna at the beginning of
the first one when they killed longclaw
and then it looked like the kitten at
the beginning were humans
yeah so yeah
it they had to be like some kind of i
almost was curious like if there would
be some kind of quick info dump of like
who his squad was
because they had the same armor but they
were yeah humanoid
much more so i drew that one a lot yeah
i was fun i was really
really really into that and i think
i was really also impressed that i think
in terms of a part two of just how
natural it was you know when you go from
something that's much smaller
to something much bigger you usually
lose the law i mean yeah you don't get
as much james morrison
the wife
seek a sumpter you don't get as much of
them it's not really about that but
they're the lessons instilled in the
center and the heart of that are very
important yeah
uh
and they
they made it better with the whole you
know
um like they didn't rely on the human
interaction they they mainly relied on
uh the
the actual the animated characters yeah
you know yeah yeah and the world
so
i was impressed with this one i thought
this was a really impressive movie
jupiter wasn't that funny
yet i still really enjoy watching him
cause i'm like conflicted on that not
even like conflicted it's
just sort of accepted this portrayal
that was really funny in the first one
um it's it's so strange to me when i
think about it because in the first one
i was more always aware it's jim carrey
and i wasn't really seeing robotnik yeah
it was always of where was jim carrey
and i thought he was funnier than the
first one and here
i i don't recall anything i really
laughed at that he did
but
he still felt like the
real villain to me
more like dr robotnik to me with a lot
of gym charisms you know yeah i mean
there's a it's funny because because
because yeah i mean i obviously laughed
through this and i i found it very funny
and charming there there is a lot
there's a weird duality i can't quite
put my finger on because it comes out
with robotnik and it also comes out in
just the rest of the the jokes in the
dialogue where i'm like there's a lot of
jokes that aren't particularly inspired
to me however there is a lot of like
really appealing charisma and really
good commitment to the characters that
bridges that gap so even if a joke seems
obvious there's still a fair uh chance
that like you know just the pizzazz and
the panache you know brought by the
actors
in voice or physically on screen you
know bridges that and it all kind of i
think it does well overall it's like i
like the humor overall more than i like
any one specific joke or something like
that but uh but i thought it got funnier
as it went too yeah i liked it i i liked
most everything kind of increasingly as
it went on yeah
well i think and because movies like
longer feels longer than the first one
and
when um
i think like with the humor too even
with knuckles i thought was handled so
well of how
it always stayed i thought like in the
very very end like just like when i said
the very very end i mean literally like
the last few lines is when i thought
maybe they're
don't push it now yeah don't overdo it
because it's been pitch perfect with the
comedy yeah
yeah um even though that some of that
baseball stuff is really funny but that
still felt right there in tune
um
but i really just mean like the last
couple of lines
the camera's not even like locked off on
him
uh
how he starts off where he's like this
really imposing serious figure and then
they slowly have like little bits to
make him a little funny
but never
making fun at him
you know like when he's reading the dot
dot dot dot
like unexpected humorous moments with
him he's got a draxness about him where
it works but it's not full drags it's
not full it is that thing of like you
know i'm a bit of a fish out of water
even though i'm really formidable and
really tough and really badass but yeah
it allows for those moments where you're
like oh yeah he doesn't
he's not accustomed to any of this so
there's a natural humor that comes out
of that and i appreciate that there are
multiple different approaches to the
humor due to yeah where the characters
are coming from like it's good that they
informed that through the characters and
idiots elba is excellent he is perfectly
he perfectly voices him more than just
being imposing you know he brought that
extra layer of heart and kudos to the
animators too because
that
there i felt for him that you know a lot
of those see like when he had that
speech to
uh
because obviously it's not bad like this
this was all predictable from the tr
like the main plot beats were
predictable from the trailer you know
uh but that doesn't bother me because it
was still so
wondrous and dazzling and fun and
exciting and it seemed like they really
cared a lot and and the movies shot so
well like they really
amped up the way it looks
um
again it feels like progression instead
of reinvention and i think that's so
neat that they managed to still honor
the vibes of the first one but just
really up the ante
in terms of the the stakes and the scale
of everything yeah and uh i lost my
first train of thought but my first my
first point was something about
knuckles but yeah when knuckles has that
speech when he's saying to robotnik when
he's realized robotnik's gonna get the
emerald yeah you know i you're my friend
like you feel how betrayed he is because
knuckles is so what we've seen
throughout the movie is he's so honest
yeah you know he's so under no not one
bit of him feels manipulative and feels
very like his whole character up being
honorable so i felt bad for him yeah and
then
when robotnik betrayed when he saw
robotnik betraying him i actually felt
really bad for him yeah so when he has
that moment on the on the sand with um
sonic i thought that was really sweet
like it is it still has that big heart
and uh
and it like evolves into like almost an
avengers like feeling but yeah when
they're all like crossing fans working
together like that's a big circle
yeah they made me think of the events
yeah totally
yeah yeah a lot of wish fulfillment yeah
yeah but in a way that's that's not too
in your face or not going see see what
we're doing like it evokes the avengers
in a moment like that but it's not going
hey guys avengers well they earned the
moment yeah they they naturally got
there
i would have liked a little bit more
flesh on knuckle uh tails to be honest
yeah tails is the one that's still look
at credits
unless this is not looks kind of frozen
if there's another post-credit scene
yell at us and tell us that the reason
is
i don't know yeah it's like tails is not
the um
i like i like tails and i was kind of
led to believe that tails would be
less
present
i forgot someone had a review out there
that i heard that that kind of led me to
believe something i was
i i was concerned about there are a few
scenes where tails is like knocked out
and then for an extended period of time
yeah for like a good long while and so
when tails finally like really rejoins
the action it's a bit of like oh dang
tails is back yeah yeah yeah so he kind
of dips out for a little while and there
is a certain aspect of like i thought
again i love that they got the original
voice actress to do the voice and i
really liked tails personality overall
but yeah i like i feel like there's the
burden of having to introduce both of
these fan favorite characters and
knuckles
affects the main drive of the plot a lot
more like tails comes in handy and is a
really great emotional development for
sonic and is a really great physical
help to sonic with all the gadgets and
things like that and sets up a lot of
great set pieces but there are aspects
of
that character that feel more like plot
device than knuckles does certainly well
i think this is kind of a weird thing to
say but for some reason that's the thing
that's coming to mind right now
is that
as i did i did like tails i really liked
that scene at the at the um
the lodge or whatever that was siberian
roadhouse
seeing that surprised me i was like this
is bizarre to have in this movie because
i know you did [ __ ] like that on the
first one which was like a road as a
road trip movie yeah
but that worked for that and then when
that scene popped up that was like it's
kind of bizarre to have him here but
then it surprised me it was really funny
and really entertaining you know yeah
and it took a trope i don't always lie
it's funny we were just watching chip
and dale because they they make fun of
like the animated characters rapping
trope and i feel like right behind that
is the animated character dance battle
trope but but i really enjoyed it yeah
it's like it was it i
was sitting here thinking like okay are
we gonna do another big brawl or
something and i think they did nicely to
commit to like this seems like it's
about to cross a line into getting kind
of dark and uncomfortable and then yeah
the the the dance and just the way that
that especially the main bearded you
know guy is like smiling clearly like
he's a trained dancer like there's so
many just little charms and nuances that
like every time i was about to get
cynical it would bring me back you know
yeah yeah thousand percent um
that and and
tails and sonic had a scene there i
think
even though they're all
cgi animated characters
i guess tails is the one who feels the
most out of like a cartoon show
yes you know
and i and it's funny because they're
because as much as there has been a lot
of you know people excited that they
brought the again the original uh voice
actor in there is something that becomes
this uh like box or something not box
but a frame around it yeah it it yeah
it's because you've got these two other
recognizable more yeah hollywood actor i
know their face voices and then you have
like i thought her performance was great
because you know obviously it's very
suited to a an animated character like
that
but you're also then aware that yeah
it's like the third piece is different
from the other two kinda well there's
something with the writing too about i
can't quite pinpoint it i couldn't
figure it out in the moment so it wasn't
like vehemently bothering me when i was
watching it no no i just could have it
just could have had more it felt like if
anything got cut down a bit for for time
because i have to imagine this was
longer at first it was probably that
stuff i bet well other than a few plot
points kind of moving along quickly or
some things that was even the human
stuff felt
in the beginning i was like this is a
little unnecessary
you know the whole thing with the
wedding
you know which was bumming me out
because i i really i i don't think james
marston gets enough credit you know
especially in the first movie i don't
think he gets enough credit for how
great he's in i i i love him in that
first movie yeah and
i don't know how they film these movies
i don't know what he what or whom he's
interacting with on set
they do have some kind of model yeah
it's a little little guy it's a classic
little guy with this bald and cigar
hey i'm sorry
give me my chili dog i'll be in my train
yeah with chili dogs waiting for the
next setup
call me when it's time to roll
got that jimmy boy
thanks
um
but he real especially him in that first
movie
he really what makes sonic feel so alive
and like a real character is
his ability to play off of
something that's not there and he does
it so
sincerely and and has such a great
personality so i think he's a very
underrated performer in that first movie
and he brings that same level of
understanding here even though he's not
as prominent of a character yeah so
i don't know this is this movie had a
weird effect with some of the human
stuff where i would we would sometimes
check in with it and be like this is a
little unnecessary it kind of feels like
perfunctory just because it was in the
first movie but then they would do like
random stuff that would i think would be
really funny like the whole uh
volleyball scene with the guys who are
always who are just like so into working
out yeah it was really funny in the way
that comedy was captured there well the
whole long con with the yeah no beyonce
but then that made it feel more
maybe not necessary but it had to make
more sense to bring gun in and uh
yeah this like ridiculous long long con
situation was fun i found it really
entertaining and amusing and one of the
most like oh no moments to me was when
the ring was on her finger it was about
to be on her finger like that was like
oh [ __ ] yeah
yeah so it surprised me what something
that was making me feel initially like
this is not feeling necessary we're like
pointlessly checking in
to oh my god i'm really enjoying this
and this stuff i thought the movie got
better it already started off like on a
good note and it just got better for me
it didn't ever descend or i wasn't like
come on and you know yeah even though
sometimes i could feel the length i i i
would never get the only reason i could
feel the length is probably because we
could see the timer occasionally because
you love how we're watching this but if
i wasn't i would i every time that timer
was gone i would be
um uh
not giving a [ __ ]
just enjoying it yeah yeah totally i
mean i think there are you know fair
criticisms you could level partly
because like for example just like with
distribution of attention and pacing
like yeah once you do get back to hawaii
and that becomes its own whole thing you
sort of like take a break and spend a
bunch of time you know with all the
chaos happening with the human
characters and so like i feel like there
are multiple ways to look at this
because yeah like
you could probably
take the plot and make it more
streamlined or proportionate but again
just every
every
next step of the story or every next
location or something it just comes back
to that where anytime i started to feel
a lag or to feel like oh this isn't very
inspired in this moment or that moment
you know it would it would then turn
around and charm me again so like
there's nothing in this movie that i
didn't like or that i wanted to come out
you know i feel like yeah you could
maybe proportion it well but i think
it's a it speaks
to how much goodwill can come when your
heart is in the right place and the
spirit of the movie is on point and two
i think
it's funny and sometimes it's kind of
plot hole-ish but i think it's also
charming that like the human
the physics and the stakes surrounding
the human characters
still feel
like they're kind of plugged in even
though there's a lot that's like
kind of cartoonish in terms of like how
much peril they're actually in
like uh you know um
yeah it's like when the car flips over
and then the next shot they're just
crawling out of the car and everything's
fine you know little things like that
but uh yeah like they they they did a
nice job at escalating everything and
balancing i feel like you could easily
go too far
with some of the intensity in something
like this or or across a line into being
like who is this really for young
audiences too anymore but i think they
rode that line nicely and there's some
really just impressive
from a technique standpoint little
moments and set pieces like when uh so
you know eggman first comes back while
sonic is at the house and they have all
these handheld shots that have to be a
lot harder for animators and digital
artists to track and to make
you know the character look as true in
those more intense because yeah you
choose to shoot it that way because that
camera motion and that inherent you know
uh that inherent motion gives you a
certain sense of dread and i appreciate
that they didn't skimp on stuff like
that or yeah when the giant uh you know
death egg mekbot you know comes out at
the end
it's like a really chilling sinister
shot when you've just got that backlight
and all the smoke and so i i think
again you could easily go too far with
that but i thought they did that nicely
and they also tempered it well with
making it feel at times like you're
progressing through a video game and
using certain
you know puzzle based uh scenarios or
things like that
everything at the island at the end
especially yeah things like that to
enhance the journey and to also make you
think back to like oh yeah like even
though this is transcribed in a way
that's very cinematic especially those
moments where they're all like you know
they're running really fast and they're
fighting people off and stuff like that
like you know those take you back to the
game because that's so much of what
you're doing is just side scrolling and
you know fighting bosses and collecting
rings and stuff and
and yeah it's like
i feel like some video game movies
do those things but in a clunky sort of
like we're doing the video game thing
way and i didn't feel that way here
no i i don't feel left out because i
don't because i'm not
strongly familiar with sonic i'm really
not
strongly familiar
um i've become more acquainted only in
like the past couple of years
like not gonna lie won't and that's
that's when it was
so
uh to
so to watch a movie like this i'm never
like i don't you won't feel left out i
mean maybe super saiyan sonic would make
more sense to someone
but i wasn't there going like what i
don't get it uh
i i think
this these two movies have established
itself as the best i i think they are
like
like possibly the best video game live
action movies they for the genre that
they inhabit
like yes there's video game it's like i
wouldn't compare this with like freaking
mortal kombat like they're different
genres
however if we're talking about video
game movies there's a certain
qualitative way these are
done that i think is really hard to beat
i think they are the best the best ones
um
like uh i i think the in terms of the
visually the way they they upped they
upped it here it was so much more
composed and stylistic but it felt still
like
like it was never trying too hard yeah
it was
and managed to make every action scene
so cool
like it was cool it was exciting it was
fun
and
i like what they did with robotnik here
because it's the focus is more about
like um you know that the betrayal's
around the corner but
you know like with robotnik being more
unhinged and
and then giving him like the ultimate
power at the end like it it felt like
sometimes in
most movies it would be like we got to
the master emerald it's time for this
movie to wrap up come on mm-hmm and and
to me it felt natural to get to that
point where you had something that big
and that brought them together you know
kind of like the way a lot of people
felt how i felt the first time like i
really appreciate bvs over time but the
first time i watched pbs when it was
like oh superman and batman are done
fight oh god now we got doomsday yeah
a lot of movies might feel like a little
bit perfunctory in that way and and this
didn't have that effect i i thought it
it kept a certain pulse about it that
i was always um i was always really into
and
to
to really know the franchise you're
telling from the first movie of sonic
being this guy who
is alone and has to learn how to
um face his problems not run away from
his problems and then here now that he's
been accepted into something that's
about
they beat it over the head here with uh
with accepting or learning to be
responsible and responsible for others
you know not just feeding your own image
but really looking after people and
protecting others as well
i thought was
just a nice one-two combo you know
because i was with the way they were
foreshadowing some stuff i was like are
they gonna end on a note where sonic's
not going to be with james marston
anymore you could
go live in this thing and get an
apartment yeah
is that where they're going because i
don't want to go there with that so the
note they ended on was even um
stronger to me i i really the first when
i rewatched the first sonic movie uh a
couple months ago
i liked it so for some reason i didn't
like i didn't like it that much when i
first saw it
um and then when i re-watched it i
thought it was really for some reason i
was able to just
uh and appreciate it and really enjoy it
for for what it was it's like a really
good family movie
and brought me to tears the first when i
rewatched it i like it towards the end i
was really so into it i thought it was
really badass at the end with sonic
so to have this sequel follow through
with that because i am not
part of the camp that
most of the time i i don't like the
human characters like everyone else and
i like the humans
in these movies i do
i i really enjoy the sheriff character
like is kind of off and on for me the uh
whatever that silly cop is he's off and
on for me but for the most part i really
enjoy the main humans
where a lot of movies they're like god
they're boring stop
and
and while they're not the highlight to
me
i really enjoy them still and i really
think they add to the film
so
yeah like i i i thought this movie was
working for me in in a lot of ways i was
i had a really great time see that's the
key to the debate for me of figuring out
which one i like better because that's
that's maybe the one thing this my
favorite thing about the first movie was
just the the james martin the donut king
and sonic relationship yeah and there's
way less of that here which is a bit of
a bummer to me because i do miss that in
a little i do it because it does take as
much as there is heart in this movie it
does take some of the
the biggest beatingest heart aspects
from it and trades them for bigger
circumstances which i don't begrudge it
because i think they handle that stuff
well it's just kind of a personal flavor
thing so i'm curious to see how this
movie sinks through
uh you know in the next couple of days
but i did like i think that's why i keep
bringing up the first one as well
because i i keep viewing them as a
package that's a good point because they
do feel very natural one out of the
other and they it doesn't feel like oh
we got to find some weird way reason to
justify bringing all these people back
like yeah it feels very natural and the
comedy coming out of them
is very natural and i mean one of my
favorite parts of this movie too was the
whole thing with randall
you know which is you know a different
flavor with the human characters so yeah
they definitely brought some new stuff
to appreciate
and yeah just a ton of imagination and a
ton of you know it's
you could really tell everybody wanted
to have like bring their best energy to
this even if i didn't always find it
inspired from like uh
you know from a screw like a dialogue
standpoint at least i thought they
really had their hearts in the right
place on pretty much everything
uh yeah you say i would have more of
those issues like with the first sonic
movie the first time i saw it but for
some reason i'm just not as peeved by
those things anymore yeah the thing is
now i'm i'm wondering if if if watching
it again i'll have the same reaction
because it's already
it's like i was watching it i was i was
kind of coming along and
and at first i was like yeah it's all
right you know it's fun and then it
would it got me more and more as it went
on and now as i'm sitting here and we're
talking about it like you know you you
have i feel like sometimes you watch a
movie and you're kind of mulling your
thoughts and then yeah the more you
start to discuss and analyze it then you
feel that rise within where you're like
no i'm i'm kind of excited about this
yeah like you know you can feel that
that good energy raising up so i think
this is
yeah i i think this is one i'll come
back too and and you know really i'm
excited to actually do that to go back
and watch them both now in tandem and
kind of revisit and i think they work
really well back to back i bet yeah i
mean i can already two months apart
three minutes before
no but even sitting here like even
sitting here just with this and then my
recollection of the previous movie i'm
like yeah no i could absolutely imagine
that like this i i could imagine how
someone might go watch it both the sonic
movies back to back that could get
tedious and i'm like but i don't think
it would for me no i don't think it
would be because the first one is so so
much smaller and simpler
yeah
and this is um
it's still like i said i keep saying it
feels like a big progression
but not a leap the way how some people
felt with take for example one division
versus how would you catch up with wanda
multiverse and madness yeah just like
what a what a leap we've gone to
the whole other movie yeah
yeah you know that like i think i do
view them as like a back to back of uh
even though they're very different they
feel appropriately this feels like an
appropriate part too yeah um yeah i'm
not sure because that is my favorite
part of the first movie too is that
heart between them and and that really
that real personal touch with sonic in
that first one and sonic and james
martin well because that is the one
aspect of the road movie that that i
think is
yeah it's like it's easy to overlook but
it's the most plugged in in that first
movie is a road movie partly is about
watching
usually two people you know really go on
a journey together tied to each other
but uh
but there are things in here that are
not in the first one that are so great
here too and different forms of heart
yeah and different forms of connection
that i thought were really strong yeah
and it suits the messages about growing
up and being more independent and
thinking beyond just taking care of
yourself yeah
and uh and knuckles brings a new kind of
flavor too knuckles is really something
special in this movie yeah knuckles
right and i love that they were able to
make it like i totally forgot too like
when sonic charges up and they're going
at each other i totally forgot about the
whole block yeah yeah and like it's all
i think it's always to to a movie's
credit when they can do that because i
mean i've seen that trailer a bunch of
times and i just wasn't thinking about
it and i still got that
moment out of it so i i had a lot of fun
with this one
me too all right guys well what do you
think about sonic the hedgehog 2
leave your thoughts down below what are
you looking forward to in sonic 3
everyone's shouting shadow at me right
now
but hey let's end this with a
patron of the day shout out
daniel gallacher this is exactly the
movie to shout out for you because who
is the closest person to being
a red mustachioed person at this patreon
it would be you because you live in
scotland and even though in your profile
pic it doesn't look like you have red
hair a lot of scottish folks
got red hair and if they got a mustache
that means the mustache also gonna be
red that's what i thought of when i
thought of you so true and this movie
plus i bet you like a good latte with
some good foam art on it like how could
you ever turn down your face
staring back at you in a mug
full of warmth and goodness
hey
i bet you got a tail buddy
and some knuckles to crack
and i miss any ways in which daniel
could suit this movie i'm trying to
think of of maybe
like james marston you know taking care
of family taking care of ones he loves
maybe someday he'll get married
to to somebody
and uh and uh and they'll be uh an agent
of some kind don't make blackjack i
didn't mean to i'm sorry they'll be um
an asian of some kind that's okay and
they'll just be a regular person maybe
approach too sensitive yet with that
yeah yeah we wait for society to say
something that's right and then we go
yeah you're right sorry guys i did never
mean it
but anyway daniel gallacher
you're the doctor robotnik in my heart
[Music]